messieurs bonsoir cet homme qui derrière
moi est à la tête d'une des plus grosses
fortunes de france est un des dix grands
leaders de l'économie française c'est le
baron empain
et bien ce matin il a été enlevé en
plein paris alors qu'il est personne
n'est capable de dire quel est le mobile
du rapt aucune demande de rançon n'a été
formulée
alors s'agit-il donc d'un rapt à
l'italienne du style de celui de
monsieur révelli beaumont en avril
dernier
ou bien d'un enlèvement à l'allemande
comme celui de hans martin schleyer en
septembre rien ne permet encore de le
dire avenue foch rival des champs
elysées quant au prestige et le lieu de
résidence préférée des plus riches
familles
c'est dans la contre-allée de droite que
l'enlèvement a eu lieu peu avant 11
heures lorsque la 604 venait de quitter
le numéro 33 domicile du baron empain
hauteur du numéro 10 est un cyclomoteur
lui a barré la route d'une camionnette
est là en stationnement de gangsters
masqué en surgissent revolver braqué le
cyclomotoriste lui aussi sort un
pistolet le baron empain est emmené dans
sa propre voiture par deux hommes seuls
véritables témoins du temps du rapt le
chauffeur qui a été jeté dans les staffs
est et qui devaient être relâchés peu
après porte maillot
la concierge du 17 bis a pu cependant
fournir quelques vagues indications
12h10 heure trente il n'y avait rien je
suis descendu et j'avais appelé la
police pendant les rangs une voiture ce
qu'il est totalement différent de la
faire et à ce moment là aux croyances et
de la folie j'ai entendu du bruit
totalement de portières et une voiture
redémarrer mais vous avez entendu du
bruit j'ai entendu du bruit j'ai entendu
des craquements de portières 33 heures
après l'enlèvement du baron empain c'est
toujours l'incertitude la famille n'a
reçu aucun message des ravisseurs
on ignore s'il s'agit de l'enlèvement
politique ou d'un acte de banditisme
dans la 604 d'ubs argument pas retrouvé
hier soir dans un parking de la porte
champerret il y avait bien ne savait en
cuir et plusieurs trousseaux de clés
mais ces objets n'ont pas permis de
faire progresser l'enquêté
il appartenait au baron empain les
policiers ont alors cherché à arrêter
les ravisseurs dans les mailles d'un
gigantesque dispositif de contrôles
organisés sur la région parisienne
cent quarante mille véhicules et deux
cent quarante mille personnes ont ainsi
été contrôlés en vain reste les coups de
téléphone anonymes divers et
contradictoires reçue par plusieurs
organes de presse
doivent-ils vraiment être prise au
sérieux le groupe d'extrême gauche n'a
pas démenti ce soir dans un communiqué
être à l'origine du rapt la police
néanmoins ne néglige aucune piste
la police n'exclut dans cette affaire
aucune hypothèse et procède bien
évidemment à toutes les vérifications
à l'heure où je vous parle c'est à dire
à 18 heures il n'a pas été possible
d'authentifier ces coups de téléphone
est ce que vous pensez franchement que
le nhs à papeete une organisation
suffisamment structurée pour se livrer à
une telle rapt je vous répète que tant
que la police n'a pas d'éléments lui
permettant d'avoir des certitudes
elle envisage toutes les hypothèses
quels sont les éléments concrets ce soir
en dehors de ces coups de téléphone il
n'y a pas d'autres éléments concrets
donc à l'heure où je vous parle toutes
les hypothèses restent encore possibles
alain cayol une double personnalité
étonnante le jour honorable marchands de
bibliothèque à montpellier et la nuit
redoutable chef de bande à paris cailhol
s'est d'ailleurs présenté comme un
simple comparses ne connaissant rien à
la faire et puis il a compris que s'ils
voulaient sauver sa tête aux assises
ils avaient tout intérêt à reconnaître
que les policiers étaient maintenant
maître du jeu et que seule la libération
du baron empain
pouvait lui permettre d'échapper à la
guillotine d'où l'incroyable coup de
téléphone passé par alain cayol depuis
un bureau de la police judiciaire à ces
hommes à ceux qui détenaient le baron
empain
nous allons revenir en détail sur tous
ces points qu'un auteur de séries noires
n'aurait jamais osé imaginer
mais d'abord les circonstances de la
libération du ballon du baron empain
avec christian barquisseau arts place de
l'opéra un homme sort de la station de
métro et entre drogue store c'est le
baron empain
aussi extraordinaire que cela puisse
paraître le baron traverse les boutiques
les bars les restaurants descend
jusqu'aux cabine téléphonique un long
trajet sans que personne ne le remarque
pas même la préposée qui lui vend le
jeton de téléphone soixante trois jours
de captivité l'ont bien changé là il
fait son numéro à l'autre bout du fil
une femme tremble d'émotion
reconnaissant la voix de son mari
libérer quelques minutes plus tôt dans
une ruelle d'ivry ses ravisseurs lui ont
donné juste l'argent nécessaire pour
prendre le métro est téléphoné à sa fin
le temps d'arriver de l'avenue foch et
ce sont les retrouvailles après 63 jours
de captivité
le baron en pas très fatigué demande aux
policiers de rentrer d'abord chez lui il
parlera après avoir un peu récupéré 23
heures le commissaire ottavioli chef de
la brigade criminelle arrive avenue foch
il faut pour lui tout faire maintenant
pour capturer toute la bande des
ravisseurs le baron livre alors les
renseignements sur les circonstances et
le déroulement son rapt un peu après
minuit le commissaire ottavioli sort du
domicile de l'industriel et c'est la
ruée des journées au a fait prévenir qu'
il valait mieux libérer le ballon parce
qu'il ya une remise de rançon je pensais
qu'il pourra nous parler tout va sans
doute aller très vite maintenant dans
l'enlèvement du baron empain
les policiers de la brigade anti gang et
de la brigade criminelle ont arrêté l'un
des ravisseurs et en ont abattu un autre
hier soir sur l'autoroute du sud au
moment où un représentant de la famille
en pin allait remettre la rançon
cet homme au moment où il s'est arrêté à
côté d'une borne téléphonique sur
l'autoroute du sud près de paris a vu
surgir des gangsters qui ont pris la
rançon sont montés dans ces voitures ont
fait quelques centaines de mètres se
sont arrêtés près d'autres complices et
ces derniers constatant la présence de
policiers dans plusieurs voitures
banalisées ont immédiatement ouvert
le feu sur les hommes des commissaires
leclerc et broussard deux policiers de
la brigade anti gang ont été
sérieusement blessés la rançon a été
récupérés intacts
elle se montait à 17 millions de francs
suisses environ 4 milliards de dhs
anciens francs trois ravisseurs ont
réussi à prendre la fuite et je voulais
dit l'un d'entre eux a été tué et
l'autre blessé légèrement a été
interrogé toute la nuit au quai des
orfèvres à paris et il semble bien
d'après les renseignements que nous
avons pu obtenir que les policiers
connaissent maintenant beaucoup de
choses dans l'enlèvement du baron empain
et qu'un dénouement devrait intervenir
rapidement
ceux qui ont enlevé le baron empain sont
très probablement identifiés dans leur
quasi totalité le baron empain est donc
toujours vivant on pense d'ailleurs que
les gangsters qui semble être des gens
du milieu vont probablement se disperser
pour échapper à la police et qu'ils ont
tout intérêt à libérer le baron empain
vivant afin de ne pas aggraver un
dossier déjà épais les ravisseurs risque
déjà la peine de mort mais il est
évident que si le baron empain est
retrouvé vivant et toute l'expérience
judiciaire le pauvre les ravisseurs ont
une chance de sauver leur tête
mais revenons à la fusillade d'hier soir
sur l'autoroute du sud
éric gilbert c'est le rendez vous sur
l'autoroute du sud dans le sens province
paris
le négociateur devait arrêter la voiture
de la rançon un break r12 devant une
borne téléphonique
lorsqu'il arrivera vers 20h30 deux
banques terre en kaboul l'éjecter rond
du véhicule ce qu'ils ne savent pas
c'est que demandent eux il ya une aire
14 de la brigade antigang et derrière un
fourgon peugeot également bourrés de
policiers la suite le commissaire
ottavioli la réponse
[Musique]
à ce moment là notre dispositif
d'intervention a pris en chasse cette
voiture qui d'ailleurs s'est arrêté
quelques centaines de mètres plus loin
les ravisseurs et à l'intention de
sortir la rançon par une porte du mur de
protection contre les bruits d'arcueil
qui donnait sur arcueil et lorsque cette
voiture a été entourée par notre
dispositif en réalité des individus qui
se trouvaient derrière la porte tout
ouvert le feu ce dispositif dispositif
qui a répliqué nous avons eu deux
inspecteurs blessés forte heureusement
légèrement est l'un des individus qui
étaient venus prendre un rançon a été
tué tandis que l'autre a été légèrement
blessé et est interrogé la fusillade en
fête a été d'une violence inouïe
tous les véhicules sont criblés de
balles en moins d'une minute en attirer
plusieurs centaines de projectiles
les gangsters en effet disposer d'un
véritable arsenal
[Musique]
je dois dire armés de fusils
mitrailleurs et de pistolets
automatiques et de grenades
on frémit à l'idée de ce qui aurait pu
se passer si c'est grenade avait explosé
sur l'autoroute mais les policiers
avaient ordre de s'opposer à tout
paiement de rançons et ils ont agi
autant qu'on sache en accord avec le
groupe
enfin il est difficile de savoir quelle
sera la conséquence de l'opération
mais le commissaire broussard de la
brigade antigang semblait
particulièrement confiant hier soir et
les enquêteurs pensent que le baron
enfin et toujours vivant
les négociations ne sont ne se sentent
engagés que dans la mesure effectivement
où le groupe avait la conviction que le
bronze est tendue autre élément
important le gangster arrêtait alain
cayol a avoué sa participation au rapt
et son interrogatoire pourrait bien
constituer un atout décisif pour les
policiers
monsieur bonsoir cet homme qui est assis
à mes côtés vous le connaissez tous et
vous ne connaissez mal il s'appelle
edouard jean empain pendant deux mois de
janvier à mars il ne s'est pas passé
deux jours sans que nous vous parlions
de lui son enlèvement le 23 janvier sa
libération le 28 mars son départ pour
les états unis
un départ qui ressemblait un peu à une
fuite et son retour en france il ya deux
jours à peine
alors qu'on l'avait presque oubliée
voilà comment l'actualité s'est emparée
de cet homme à ses dépens alors que
pendant 40 ans de sa vie il a souhaité
la discrétion
pourtant cet homme je vous le disais
vous ne l'avez jamais entendu vous ne le
connaissez pas vous l'avez jamais rendu
pas plus avant sa captivité que depuis
ce soir c'est sur le plateau d'antenne 2
qu'il a choisi de venir
merci edouard jean empain je vais devoir
vous poser une question qu'on ne pose
jamais la télévision
comment allez vous mais écoutez je vais
je vais très bien je vous remercie
physiquement et moralement moralement
physiquement je vais très bien je vais
en tout cas beaucoup mieux qu'il ya cinq
mois ce que j'ai encore peur par moments
par moments il m'arrive encore
de voir des images en rêve au voyeur
mais enfin ne se passe pas de jour que
que la peur ne s'estompe
est ce qu'elle est en droit d'en paris
où vous ne voulez pas retourné de suis
rentré à paris depuis maintenant 48
heures et bah disons que j'ai pas encore
osé au passé dans la contre-allée de
l'avenue foch effectivement non tu as
plus de chez vous pas plus que chez moi
je repasserai sûrement mais il faut que
je me prépare c'est difficile on va
c'est pas parler de votre séquestration
on va parler de votre départ pour les
états unis est ce que c'était une suite
un besoin de changer de peau sûrement
jeu pendant les moments de rêve quand
j'étais en captivité je l'imaginais mon
retour et je me me gênait un certain
accueil que j'aurais pu avoir je dois
dire que j'ai été un peu déçue déçue par
qui bon j'ai été déçu par j'étais déçu
d'une certaine d'une certaine
incompréhension
on m'a fait un certain nombre de procès
procès d'intention évidemment ma vie et
en été un petit peu disons décortiqué
par la police et par les miens et par
tout le monde
bien
je n'ai pas je n'ai pas trouvé la
chaleur à laquelle je m'attendais déçu
par la france pas du tout d'ailleurs je
profite de cette occasion ne sais pas
pour pour remercier les centaines de
français no name n'est ce pas qui monte
écrit à la fin du mois de mars
et je j'ai emporté beaucoup de ces
lettres dans voyages aux états unis et
je les pros lisait de temps en temps
dans sa lettre est-ce qu'elle ait
beaucoup de deux lettres de gens de
votre caste de votre 10e lui manquent
pas il y avait neuf et des lettres de
français de de tous les milieux et
particulièrement des milieux disons non
aisées c'est à dire des gens qui se font
pas partie ce qu'on appelle ma classe
classe vous allez s'est trouvée oui mais
enfin je pense que el nour et adoptera
meurent et adoptera s'est facilement est
un peu revanchard nom également
ce serait plus dur ou ou plus humain
coco par un bon je pense que sony du
plus dur ni plus humains je pense que
peut-être que je serai un peu plus un
peu plus indulgent pour ce que l'on
pourrait appeler des fautes vénielles
est peut-être un petit peu plus dur pour
des fautes plus grave qu est-ce qui
après cinq mois de repos vous paraît
aujourd'hui dérisoire est essentielle
ce qui est dérisoire en tout cas assez
de se préoccuper de l'opinion que les
autres peuvent avoir de vous c'était une
chose qui pour moi avait une certaine
importance il ya un an maintenant
sûrement pas je suis beaucoup plus
peut-être un peu détaché plus
décontracté devant les événements en
tout cas sûrement devant les
journalistes devant la télévision
ce n'est plus quelque chose qui me fait
peur c'est
allez les choses ont changé d'importance
effectivement il m'arrivait encore il ya
un an pour ce qu'un ami me demandais
qu'est ce que tu as fait hier je
répondais fréquemment où j'ai rien fait
aujourd'hui cette phrase n'a pas de sens
pour moi n'est ce pas il se passe
tellement de choses dans une journée ne
sais pas depuis son rezaï puisque son
coucher que ça la passante dire on n'a
rien fait et c est ce que ce recul
vis-à-vis de nous-mêmes certains diront
cette désinvolture que vous permettre de
prendre la tête d'un groupe financier
aussi important que le vôtre
bah écoutez je l'espère n'est ce pas en
tout cas je vais je vais tenter donc je
l'espère profondément je pense que j'ai
les moyens de reprendre ma place et je
pense que que mes collaborateurs me
suivront jusqu'à jusqu'aux événements
alors j'ai du mois de janvier ces
événements du mois de janvier pendant
quinze jours la france a été suspendu à
votre sort pendant quinze jours au
moment du mois de mars étaient tirs au
moment de votre libération on a reparlé
du bois de vaux est ce que ça en valait
la peine parce que ça en valait la peine
va écouter ses c'est vous autres
journalistes qui avaient fait une
afférentes 1 laisse passer par mois
c'est vous qui avez parlé de moi c'est
vous qui avez fait de mon rap à un
événement
à l'échelon national c'est pas un mois à
vous dire aussi si ils le méritaient ou
non à cette occasion on a beaucoup
fouillé votre vie avait regretté tout à
l'heure on a peut-être un peu salie vous
avez une mauvaise image de marque on en
a dit playboy ce playboy en blue jeans
aujourd'hui on a des joueurs de poker
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
image convenable pour un patron
vis-à-vis des employés par exemple
peut-être que je ne pense pas mais enfin
d'ailleurs sûrement je ne pense pas au
fond puisque cette partie de ma vie au
fond je n'ai pas
je ne l'avais pas disons que le public
ne la connaissait pas elle existait
depuis que depuis vingt ans j'ai
toujours aimé jouer au poker j'ai
toujours aimé aller dans des temps des
casinos non pas dans des tripots comme
il a été dit n'est ce pas un handicap
mais l'argent vous aider facile quand
même oui mais enfin disons que cette
partie de ma vie je toujours essayer de
la tenir bien relativement cacher on ne
connaissait pas ce parce personnages
vont bien maintenant
maintenant qu'on connaît ce jour là bien
le chevet de je dois vivre avec ça et
puis je dois tenter non pas de me faire
pardonner parce que je n'ai rien à me
faire pardonner m'enfin me faire
admettre tels que je suis et je suis
peut-être un petit peu différent de ce à
quoi les gens donc on a évoqué le procès
et tout ce qui va être dit autour du
procès non absolument pas n'est ce pas
ce procès n'est pas mon procès j'espère
que ceux qui seront mis sur la sellette
ne sera pas seront mes ravisseurs n'est
ce pas et non pas moi qui les ai eus
quand même à beaucoup souffrir de ces de
ces deux dernières questions edouard
jean empain il va vous paraître
peut-être un peu bizarre est ce que vous
pouvez souhaiter à la nouveaux amis ce
qui vous est arrivé au sûrement pas
seulement c'est une heure c'est une
expérience atroce et
même si elle vous change un homme oui
elle vous changez vous pouvez peut-être
un petit peu voire plus profiter de la
vie que précédemment mais ça ne m'est
même si on préfère même si on aime mieux
la vie après ce sont des épreuves
terribles
[Musique]